today i want to talk about change that
we often don't recognize
[Music]
hi there steve kaufman here again to
talk about language learning
and today i want to talk about sort of
constant change change that we often
don't recognize while we are in fact
changing
but first of all remember if you like
these videos
about language learning please subscribe
click on the bell you'll get
notifications
and come and join me at link where which
is where i learn languages
so um i want to review first of all my
statistics today today in vancouver
was not a sunny day it rained rather
heavily most of the day
i couldn't go and play golf so i may as
well
especially with covet and so forth stay
home and
really get into my arabic and sometimes
you know if you sort of just go at it
for 10
15 minutes it's difficult and i'm tired
of doing it
but if you say i'm going to do it i'm
going to do it for
three hours well you get more and more
sort of
engaged in it and i think you get you
can end up with a really good
session which is what i had today so
if you see my statistics there uh i
added
169 new known words to my known words
total
169 so i'm now up to about 18 800 and
something
my goal was to get to 20 000. i may not
reach it but i'm going to get pretty
close if i can continue
to hit you know i got 14 days to go if i
can hit
100 a day i'll certainly make it i don't
think i can
hit 100 today but we'll see what happens
and i saved 200 new links that is words
that
were new to me that i added to my
database that hopefully will become
known words at some point become you
know status three and then eventually
status four or known and i read 5889
words so while reading this material and
creating links i also read all those
words
so that was my activity today
now this whole idea of change you know i
was thinking as i was sitting there
and going through these and i thought to
myself you know
i have no real sense that from the time
i began
say at one o'clock until the time i
stopped at let's say four o'clock
i've no real sense that i improved
during those three hours
uh i have statistics telling me that i
added these known words
that i saved a bunch of words that i
read a bunch of words
i even listened quite a bit because i
now have this new technique where i
import the transcripts of my podcasts
time stamped
use the import ebook function then i end
up with
the uh if i study in sentence mode i get
these
chunks of text with the audio for that
chunk
so i begin by listening to the audio in
arabic i read it in english i can
connect the words i understand a lot of
it
and then i go through and i read it
again and i find that it's it's a it's a
wonderful way to study it's it's really
good so i am listening as well
but but the big thing was that i added
these words to my own word total so at
least on paper i achieved something
but i have no real sense that i've
improved okay
but and so then i thought of heraclitus
his famous aphorism that you cannot step
in the same river twice so
things are always changing just the fact
that i spent
three hours with my arabic my brain has
changed now i may not be aware of having
changed but then
if i go back to when i started with
arabic
it was just noise to me and and all the
writing the
writing system was meaningless to me and
now i'm able to read i'm able to hear
and understand a lot so there is this
gradual
almost imperceptible change so this is
you know heraclitus the only constant is
change things are constantly changing
and our brain is adapting to all of this
stimulus slower than we would like but
it is
constantly changing and and
what is good too is that having put that
you know solid three hours
in i really got into it and and uh
again i always quote the french uh
saying le petitville if you give
yourself a chance to get into it
then it becomes more and more enjoyable
to some extent so i enjoyed it
and um uh you know the the the point
that i want to make is
as as manfred spitzer the german neuro
scientist that i often quote
says in his book on learning he says the
brain cannot do otherwise than learn
the brain always learns but the brain
learns
slowly so again we don't have the
sense that we're learning we don't have
the sense that we're
progressing but if we look back we'll
see that we have progressed
and in fact three hours of you know
dedicated study
i have changed i have changed my brain
and as i continue in my
arabic learning i will in change i will
change more
and as i learn other languages i will
change more but always i won't be
conscious it'll be at that slow speed
but
never you never step in the same river
twice anyway i just wanted to give you
those sort of my thoughts on the day and
sort of update you on on what i was
doing in my 90 day challenge which is
only got two weeks to go
okay thanks for listening bye for now